all right it's a daily rapid Arena on me
chess org I just joined Oh
let's turn this off I'm not gonna have
this today how do I do this meet that
this good luck to my opponent bash let's
play E for graded 1165 oh maybe I should
have desserts too late now I'll play
King's gambit a lot of people have been
requesting Kings gambit lately or maybe
it's just one person requesting at
multiple times okay the requesting has
paid off Queen h4 Queen h4 is sometimes
a good move but not in this position
because of g3 now the Queen has to go
back to where I came from now I'll take
a free pawn so now black is playing some
sort of King's pawn gambit I got
basically one two three I got four moves
in a row and black still has all the
pieces on the back rank I have three
Center pawns in the center yeah life is
pretty good
keep pushing pawns all my moves in this
game have been pawn moves I'm just gonna
keep pushing pawns because all these
pawn moves make sense
maybe black will take the consents he's
debating it okay Bishop b6 let's keep
pushing pawns I want to trap the bishop
this is so funny eight pawn moves to
start the game and I'm not even like
fooling around like I'm trying to play
the best moves
Larr Cellini the first person in the
chat welcome coming in a good time I
still have all eight pawns oh let me
turn off the AC
d6 d6 I came in the bishop I might lose
a pawn we might see takes takes maybe
pawn takes and then d5
okay the first 10 moves have been pawn
moves and I'll play d5 eventually I'll
run out of the pawn moves unless I don't
run out of pawn moves
I mean maybe I'll just keep pushing and
then eventually Queen somehow expecting
the knight to move here here I feel like
this is definitely YouTube worthy I
catch a winning game without moving any
of your pieces I'm still wanting to
expand gain more space hello to people
in the chat stock vez al masud the fook
sia homra ding MA TESOL cartoon cartoon
oh now my pawns attacked I mean I could
counter-attack how bad is d6 or how good
is g6 I feel like it's time to develop a
peace
yeah let's develop a peace so if you're
just joining my first 12 moves in this
game where pawn moves and all of them
really just made sense I went up a
bishop now it's probably time to develop
even more pieces you're a wizard Danny
or you're a downy wizard whatever your
name is
welcome back alright I'm gonna keep
developing mr. James face I troller from
Earth hopefully that's where most people
are from show though RN Hanks el rastro
doc say ok
a 5
tempting me to push another pawn I'll
just take like a trade Brooks
can now maybe see five it feels
overextending but it can be reinforced
with Bishop III listen my space
advantage people wishing me a nice
haircut or just saying nice haircuts
I'm always conflicted when I get a
haircut they ask me what I want all I
want them to do is cut my hair
so yesterday I I did like the haircut so
I had the barber just take a picture of
all angles so now I know now I can just
show show them a picture next time be so
much more efficient all right 90 to
continue developing getting ready to
castle
I think I still have the win streak it's
like at around 70 games at least in
rapid chess I looked up my stats I think
it was yesterday you know took my
profile I have some nice some nice
trophy good this trophy rapid top 10 I
try and keep it that way
papouli with an interesting emote and as
Baliga hello okay
developing defending so it didn't take
too long to develop all the minor pieces
I think I want to play each three next
there's still a lot of things yet to do
also did I just miss a fork maybe it's
more comfortable defending now if here
there's a pin oh let's play Queen a for
getting out of any potential pin
threatening d6 yeah I probably should
have played t6 in this position takes
takes but I like my pawns I don't mind
missing out on winning a piece warp
rules I'm playing rapid chess and I'm
doing well thanks for joining it's
afternoon here to 11 p.m. I'm in America
I'm in merica
according to nightbot I do have a
tournament command if people want to
join the same tournament I'm in you can
click the link in the chat and maybe you
got a chance to play
it started tournament started at 12
minutes ago some people have already won
2 games b5 I could want the song I could
take with him nice let's take with the
knight attacking the Queen hello from
India a hash hash a gem what time is it
in India it's gotta be like evening
I'd guess 11 p.m. maybe the ultimate
edge subscribing for five months thanks
so much
okay let's castle or let's push good
push but I actually don't want the night
to sacrifice itself so let's castle Oh
hyung uh oh my gosh I just hung
everything thankfully I've work fp1
castling was a little bit careless my
opponent see it you saw it
okay it's not the end of the world
that's the thing like when you have such
a nice position everything soon seems to
be going well it's easier to get
careless also when you get too
distracted by the chat oh what's new
Erik anything fun in the works I'm
playing a tournament tomorrow I'm
playing us chess champs I should have
another command to link the tournament I
don't think they're doing commentary and
unfortunately for it but maybe I'll have
an upcoming command do I have an
upcoming command okay this is a fork oh
but there's this move Queen D three
Queens III rook b3 no in the
papouli thanks for the sub let me try
upcoming okay that didn't work so let's
do commands and upcoming I'll be playing
STL Congress may what's today May 14
what's the date today
Oh May 15 so from May 16
wait this is a free queen through twenty
seconds more information okay my pots
doing work let's take a pond life is
still very good I am still learning to
learning how to add my pot commands in
the chat have I ever made a veggie
smoothie with ginger and turmeric
I bought turmeric once just because it
had Eric in it I never use it but I do
have I have a Vitamix I think what I'll
do very soon I'll make some some nice
Vitamix concoctions I'm actually
thinking about doing like a a challenge
where one day out of the week I do
absolutely no chess I do like anything
else that I'm interested in so I might
just make a video on like Vitamix stuff
okay Queen c7 coming why not take a rook
on a six
do I miss something I took the Queen on
a six
it's more valuable in the rook green tea
smoothie
yeah there's endless possibilities let's
push some more pawns d7 coming
now some people already have six points
look at this oh I can't show it let me
expand this a little bit more
so there's competition okay I don't
think this game is gonna take much
longer than a minute
yeah the term I'm playing in at least my
section does not offer GM norms I'm
playing the I am norm section and I'm
one of the ions so because I'm playing
there's a chance for other players to
get iron norms oh my gosh I was thinking
about doing this rook takes something
rookie AIDS but then takes okay but
there's so many ways to win I think I'll
still take here and I'll just take back
with the pot and then Bishop c6 rook
eight Bishop takes a athonite promotes
nice finish alright nice game maybe
that's YouTube worthy that was a fun
opening I'll show it one more time for
the people just joining my first 12
moves were pawn moves and they were all
reasonable like Kings gambit lock plate
slightly dubiously then black played
even more dubiously
maybe one advice for one piece of advice
for my opponents I think I kept pushing
pawns until 9 s6 and I had to go back
[Music]
yeah I think what happened my opponent
developed pieces to where they could
very easily be kicked around like Queen
h4 g3 was very very simple and then
later Bishop before again c3 the bishop
had to move so sometimes when you
develop your pieces you have to
acknowledge what your opponent might do
to attack them so against Kings gambit
specifically what can I recommend Bishop
c5 is a simple simple line if you if you
have very little opening knowledge and
you just want something simple I think
Bishop c5 you're threatening to take and
then play Queen h4 because I would win
h2 and there is a trap here not too many
people would fall into but if takes
Queen h4 is waiting for a black g3 takes
and you win the rook okay let's go back
to the tournament I go back daily
Rapanui okay I'm in the top hundred
eighty fifth place two points ax
villager in the chats next villager I am
liking the redesigned
oh how am i liking the redesign I assume
edge Moravsky is asking about version
two
I like it I mean it's very very similar
there there's a few few nice features
the speech synthesis is really nice
along with the type to move
well let's play g6
let's play some weird opening I'll play
Bishop g7 I'm just playing some like
modern defense we all play like c6 the
idea is to put a lot of pressure against
this pawn like now Bishop g4 and all the
pieces even though White's controlling
the center all the pieces have some
clear purpose can I do a video
explaining opening traps in a little in
the London oh my gosh am I am I did I
just wonder I think I just or maybe it's
not so bad I fell for one of these like
very simple opening shots so takes have
to move back thankfully all windy for so
we're just training but that was
completely unnecessary that's not so bad
if you want okay I did a whole video
course on opening traps and in the
London or tactics in the London I should
say so Tobias von arcs if you want that
you can click the link in the chests I
think that link gives you like the best
price because if you drop to try and get
it on the main website it's like double
the price I mean I could take here but
then King d1 in my knight and Queen and
Bishop would be hanging so let's take
here and I'll play Queen d7
yeah this is actually not so bad I'm
wondering if this is actually a playable
line like Bishop g4 it looks so
attractive least initially should
probably start with maybe I don't know
9f 636
okay so Bishop d2 so we'll have some
more positional game trying to figure
out like my ideal setup this Knight
wants to go here but it blocks of Bishop
so there is like this idea it's also
this idea I mean II six looks like the
most kind of natural move I'll play in
87 equal material queenless mobile game
half open F file life is decent
could be worse I'll play rook hf8 later
okay cha fades
I want to go for a six and B five maybe
before white wants to go for h4 h5 just
kind of scary do I have b5 immediately
takes rook b8 Knight c3 takes I also
have takes and white has to take back
with a pawn because the bishops
defending this not sure how great that
is a six this is also an issue
so b5 and I takes me five rook b8 Knight
c3 takes takes hmm and if here here here
h5 be 492 apologies for the house sounds
I could play h5 mmm after h4 I'm also
looking taking bring my knight to like
c4 or even a 5 nothing looks so
appealing yo how's it going I'm gonna
play a six good morning it's 2:24
[Music]
okay so if H four okay
I'll have to worry about that
myeeeeh 'too I'm just gonna gain space
push pawns like Lasky that's slightly
delayed how do you change your name
color on mobile I don't think you can
you can change it on desktop I think all
right
c5 it's a difficult position there's no
like clear targets it's hard to attack
e4 I could play d5 don't really want to
do that
hey listen this we gotta play a five I
just wanna play a four a three White's
going for trades I'm happy with the
trade let's continue to to gain space
you assume f5 is getting played next f5
I think losses appalling I have four
pieces defending there's only three
pieces supporting so yeah 92 expected
it's gonna take work to win this I'm
thinking my rook my rooks both belong in
that file because this pawn if I'm well
controlling f5 this pawn is slightly
backwards even though it's not like a
typical backward pawn it's hard to
advance so it's the main focal points
maybe c5
don't just expands d5 coming soon
h5 man play king c6 trying to keep up
the pace
and I think I want to play d5 if takes I
take back with pawn I'll just keep
pushing c3
okay I'll play d5
it was still very much of a fight equal
material
I think blocks slightly better because
these rooks can be considered passive
these works are active could consider
light takes ideas of 93 the problem with
night takes is this pawn is weak and
then the square is also a week so I'll
take a pond so it's three on two on the
Queen side and two on three on the Kings
side so we could have some race scenario
mhm III wants to play off five next
think about f5 I don't think it's
threatening maybe it's running f6 h5
doesn't look appealing
for some idea of playing like rook a 1
you'll start with rook 81
it's a half woven file King bee one is
probably expected
now this night needs improvement in
night c8 f v ro k 7 takes probably
doesn't work I could play this I 5 I
hear 6 ticks
I'm getting low in time to unite c8i
five takes all right I'm gonna play d4
it's a double-edged move I give away a
e4 but I get the square and maybe the
square later yeah still doing okay on
time but my phone's playing well I
botched the opening and it wasn't so bad
and now it's getting tricky again yeah
so this is what I was looking at
so if takes I take on f2 takes takes
there's no broke f6 check
it's my night controls that six there is
h5 takes takes but I'm hoping that like
this these pawns will be stronger than
like lights outside passer because maybe
I can create some mating attack like c4
d3 even like bring the rook in and
checkmate somehow I think I have to take
I'll have this move expecting pawn takes
hitting the nights I've worked g2 I have
neither for of winning upon me rook g2
that move have to calculate rook g1 King
C to check King d3 so I could play this
immediately and then rook g1 is a made
threat how does white stop that
I'm just gonna play it
because rook g1 I mean if gave b3 rook
g1 King bee 291 okay that's a good move
probably so now I can come from behind
so I've been king Oh King d5 906 let's
come from behind first I'll put the rook
here oh there's Mike G 3 tonight g3 rook
h3 getting tricky
wait Knight g3 rook h3 rook f3 takes
takes Knight f1 King D 3 ticks h6 never
mind none of that is happening play this
move attacking the knight now this move
oh the same line might happen rook g6
takes takes Knight f1 King d3 it takes
h6 am i stopping the pawn somehow I
think I am after night h v h7 night f4
check the knight g6 guarding h8
oh but the King doesn't have to go to d3
ah takes takes check the king can go
somewhere else like c1 and then I lose
I'd be tragic so I have to what do i do
take six it's really annoying and I can
check maybe I'll just check first
please play king d3 it's like and the
stress now checking looks good because
now I mean d3 and this is the whole
point of like the race like okay this
pawns a bit slow and now I'm threatening
threatening me than one rook the rook g5
my king can find safety
if Knight off one there's rookie two
mates so Knights actually glued to e2
chess we've in the chat what's up chefs
we've d2 mates okay
Oh stressful there was some interesting
lines there can go back i I was ignoring
the chat for a lot of that game I did
see jab underscores comment time time
time time time yeah my time was doing
deleting but it wasn't too bad I want to
show this one it was very double-edged
yeah I want to show this line because
this interesting calculation so I was
looking at okay King d3 most natural
move and then White's almost winning but
I have this move h7 check here and then
Knight g6 the problem is that the King
can move like somewhere far away and I
can't actually stop the pond or wait I
can't stop the pond because I still have
my cheese six wait so where does the
king go probably e1 and now I'm losing
unless I have like some no this is
losing right stockfish wait swing okay
alright that was some effort that's fun
though
good game was a close one back to
tournament I have four points first
place has 18 points man just ARPA
searching some good thing I didn't
desert that game what's not just a blue
good morning mister burns in the chat go
get in the chat okay let's play it's why
I London someone was asking for London
opening traps earlier I'll try and share
some sort of secret knowledge greetings
from Brazil obrigado
I spent four years studying Spanish in
like middle school and then high school
and then I went to Brazil which is like
one of the only South American countries
where they don't speak Spanish so then I
had to learn Portuguese running low on
space oh I forgot I'm recording this
oops yeah I hit the record button and I
forgot to stop Queen b6 was interesting
Queen b6 I can play Knight c3 Mike c3 is
actually a very typical move this is a
very thematic trap in the London where
they take me to my p5 is I believe
winning
my p5 is a threat anyway you know you
search YouTube to find some rapid
termini tournaments yeah I'm playing one
right now I think it's more fun to watch
live
wait is this just winning might be fine
I think lap one and fell into some trap
because now c3 like this is a massive
threat me five is maybe some attempts
but then I probably take with the
Knights and then you know black still
can't solve the problems all right life
is very good I forgot to make tea but I
had breakfast oh can you make some tea
yeah that would be awesome
personal assistance coming to the rescue
can we see a scholars meet next game
probably enough though that had to maybe
be against the first opponents it's been
a while since I've got sort of like
scholars meals okay so this should see
seven or night see 797 takes takes looks
good wait a minute
the night see seven he has to move the
King tix takes takes also looks good
how come on at the chest bra house it's
not a house it's a cave I'm here because
I need a place to live need some shelter
some safety and some high-speed Internet
let's play 95 yeah I mean this is just a
matter of time and technique okay this
is interesting now because black is
props committing both rooks to try them
in this pawn and then I have to actually
be careful this takes takes kingi to 94
I could actually be losing in some lines
so let's be safe let's take this night
and I'll take the pawn with the Queen so
one thing I learned I've learned over
time is that you have to be always alert
especially when you're winning because
you don't want to make a fool of
yourself
okay let's I play B for here and B for
Queen a3 maybe Bishop to e3
something Bishop d3
how often do we play it over the board I
don't even know if we have a chessboard
in this place it's not fully furnished I
guess
I do want to do some like over the board
stream so I think that was really cool
we're like over the board like YouTube
videos like John Bartholomew style where
he has a camera and like there's a
chessboard and sometimes you can't see
his face but you can see like the
three-dimensional pieces I think it's a
cool format I actually ordered this
device on Amazon last night or very
early this morning it's called a capture
card allows me to hook up my my
professional like DSLR camera as a
webcam it's actually something that
golddust tory uses we have similar
cameras it just increases the video
quality if you think this is good video
quality there's a whole new level I'll
actually take a look okay I'll be right
back
I can see it I can see it
it's lady 3 want this bishop to come to
life that bishop on a 8 I hope it's not
a claustrophobic one yeah some pieces I
feel sorry for I mean at some point
black might play d5 is my queen getting
trapped wait that Bishop on 8 is now
like causing me grief thankfully I have
this move there should be seven Queen
here
wait this is slightly scary wait free
bishop
I was thinking a6 Queen 84 my 4 inches
resigns that's funny now my queen was
not getting trapped a 6 Queen a for
Bishop c6 I take they should be 7 I go
back all right back to tournament 22nd
place working my way up in the world I'm
not gonna check my winning streak I
think it's it's well above 70 at this
points these three games in this
tournament
in the art of war it says losing
opponent will fights with all the gods
yeah that's why it's hard to win a
winning position and that's why when
you're lost you should never give up all
right let's play let's play chess I'll
play d5 maybe we'll see a London g3
let's play this now I'll play b5
somewhat of a pad line I want to stop c4
castle
I think this is a stronger is the
highest rated player that I played so
far to take this slightly more seriously
of course manage my time
well the setup that I'm doing it's a
setup I'd played many times before black
just wants to gain space on the
queenside probably throwing rook c8 C
files half open
thanks so much
all right she is on the way
Queen here let's play a six
I mean we both have very solid setups
you see for me becoming Queen c7 Queen
b6 with Bishop d4 let's start with Queen
b6 the bishop d4 it leaves us undefended
my queen can move places I'll play rook
b8 my rook to e8 Knight g5 is not
possible okay
wait
my new layout doesn't fit the iPhone
screen Oh iPhone X screen
oh is that because it bleeds the bleed
over the thing so I have an iPhone but
iPhone 8 plus which I could check tweet
me a picture of what you mean can you
take a picture of like what it looks
like because I could make it smaller but
let me know if other people are having
the same issue so I have seen that type
of comment before I forgot to take
action so 92 okay thank you to take
stakes
I mean how do i improve the position
maybe they cook c7 should just take
immediately complain I'd see 595 22
trying to calculate rook c7 takes ticks
ticks ticks double pawns but to bishops
let's allow it in the meantime I just
want to double up on modern phones have
taller aspect ratio 8 by 9 I mean they
should still resize right there now
because most video content is still like
1920 by 1080 ok I'll make it slightly
smaller for the iPhone X people is that
better
maybe the board was like too close to
the edge ok let's play with two d8
[Music]
honey
alright well the board is too close to
the edge I can make it even smaller but
then people watching like fullscreen
want the board to be like nicely laid
out I'll do some testing later okay my
Queens not getting trapped my queen b4
b4 night or queen 85 before Queen a4
looks way too risky takes so I'll play
Queen and d6 they pawns hit there's
ideas of Knight c3 also ideas of rooks
III wait rook c3 is fascinating
rooks III takes takes probably doesn't
work because my takes everything falls
but now like can't play see for what to
do here
Knight c3 probably it was very strange
position everything's on the board
except a pair of pawns
hey it's bits from hiring faith
thanks for the bits I mean nine a four
here and what else to do
Queen Queen da turns into Bishop d6 97
don't play 97 this very strange position
okay now it's slightly easier to
understand
I like this configuration on the lame I
come to c5 that could be annoying 0.984
strange square but restricting this
maybe some day this and this you got
ignored twice already if you have a
question and I'm not like paying
attention it's honestly best to ask
questions between games or on my discord
I'm not really answering too many
questions during this during a a serious
game I want to keep this Bishop so we
both have kind of the same formation on
the queenside
I'm trying to evaluate I mean I slightly
prefer black but I don't know how much
it's probably approximately equal but
the fact that this pawn is just forever
backwards makes life makes life pretty
comfortable in one plan and one plan was
Queen d8 there's no Bishop d6 because
Knight b6 I want to play Bishop f6 just
get rid of one of White's best pieces
and then access c3 I play age 6/6 first
so mr. Bostick's coming I do play on
just calm I play on both we chess and
chess calm I'll probably be playing more
of the arena Kings tournaments and there
is a good portion like of was it last
week or two weeks ago it's like a week
of chess calm streams it's like with I
was with so many other streamers so we
did a bunch of collaborations
Goldust Tori hammer mamas Joe Brune okay
Bishop a wand is very mysterious Bishop
e5 looked Tenley there should be 547 but
yeah it's very positional if I get rid
of the bishops get the Queen to f6 and
then c3 is just under my control and
this pawn is actually very loose okay I
might just be o'night b3 I feel about
but I still have rook c3
okay and now I can take if my takes I
went upon if politics I'm gonna part
it's looking good
the only downside is this bishop is
claustrophobic but we can trade
everything put the bishop on c6 so I'm
up a pawn and down on time
there's no increments so I should move
quicker always playoff six yeah there's
some attempt to do tactics but then f5
so here maybe rook rook e8 I want to
play e5 my pawns belong on dark squares
they also belong further up the board
ideally on on the seventh or or the
second or first drink oh yeah let's keep
pushing we might see Bishop g2 if the
bishops got traded the my king wants to
go to d5
am i drinking and drinking tea blueberry
something something
problem is if I take then my skin gets
efore rook c8 same story so maybe I take
your first this is tricky
takes takes e4
I think it's still okay it actually
looks like it might be slightly draw but
there's one I think important idea
coming up it's the fact that I have this
breakthrough a five move
yeah like a five immediately followed by
rock aids and all I need is one open
file to come through the structure is
just so solid I think white could have
maybe played something else like rook a1
first and try a for it but maybe it's
Soviet juice too slow yeah cuz now takes
my rook will be very active g4 and b4
also this is like almost meaning it's
actually really nice I think it's some
eventual as on or I'll just win all the
pawns guess white does have rook e1 this
is a very good sign
I'll just make a queen my rook is tied
down to the fighting against Rick III
was a nice finish
I made the King in the center of the
board
all right five more rating points did I
pass mark Esserman
wait let me go to my profile I've been
like very close to Marcus Herman's
rating if we look at the leaderboard
Rapide Rapide Rapide oh no he's still
six points above me all right back to
tournaments I don't want to jinx myself
I'm in 20th place happy robots and
buzzer King and crushing people Mark
asked Herman emotes in the chat
yeah chat I've been I've been distracted
by the games sometimes it's other way
around where the the chat distracts me
from playing the games when will I
become a grandmaster I'm not sure I need
the rating I need three Norman's it's
gonna take a lot of work it's not my my
primary goal as of now very clean game
yeah those relatively clean I don't
think they're any like major mistakes
there's no point where I was like
clearly worse all right playing Chris
nacho 1998 let's play some more chests
play maybe news oh let's see what white
is up to okay we have a Catalan this is
an opening that it took me a while until
I found something I was happy to play
this black it has a very solid
reputation for whites Queen a for check
so soon 24 check
I think I can get away with c6 b5 it
does involve sacking a pawn I think it's
okay maybe five here takes takes takes
and then Bishop t7 and treated as some
sort of gambits if the Queen was back I
want to play this and it might actually
be a similar setup to last game I put
the pieces like this and I go for c5
super major pain in the chat whoa my
opponents accepting the gambit okay this
will be interesting
I'm down upon but these light squares
are kind of weak I have a light squared
bishop and ideas of rooks e1
there's some funny idea like Queen f3
rook cc8 and I'm attacking the bishop
and threatening Bishop c6 so this is
normal now I can do this I just have a
lot of initiative
I see three runs them to be for Queen d1
maybe will be played than Bishop c6
trying to calculate ship c6 9 f3 takes
up 3 pawn takes off 3 there should be 4
check Knight c3 of rook takes c3 yeah
let's start with Bishop c6 there's
really only two moves for light I could
play Bishop b4 first or take on f3 first
maybe taking or maybe there should be 4
first it's less committal
I'll see what white is up to
hey thanks for the host this generation
meets I take so now I can win back the
pond like take steak sticks looks
reasonable
and I should have should have a slightly
better position better structure fully
developed this pawn will be attacked
I'll have some initiative
so the opening actually worked out quite
well some sort of gambit but I won back
the pond I'm like still under pressure
imagining some lines like takes takes
Queen d2 and rook c1 hmm okay now I can
take on b2 maybe like would take here
takes over queen g6 is terrifying
so it takes takes takes looking good
maybe I'll consider like I'm expecting
what to take Cowpat is Queen d6 it's 95
rook team one that looks pretty bad all
right I went from being down upon to
being up upon all Castle next move I
have a time advantage
we can trade some more of ticks and a
sevens tender wait a minute
oh no that doesn't work his check 25
maybe than 93 so White's trying to get
initiative between c4 or even 95 95
takes takes 93 there's some nice trick
Queen a 593 and then rook c8 over then
Queen takes b5 so maybe Queen a 593 just
a 6
there's also a 4 so queen a5 a4 b4 okay
just trying to be safe
yeah I didn't want to trade Queens even
though I'm not material I don't want to
a lot of whites so much activity so long
tournament still hour and 22 minutes
left happy robot has 31 points let's
play before
so I have a passed pawn which is very
easy to defend like 95 rook b8 c3 is
under my control if my d2 I might
consider rooks III
hey the abandoned castle subbing for
four months
Brooks III rooks c3 Knight c4 Queen g5
wait there's weird stuff rook c3 rook c1
ticks here
oh but then don't think that works for
whites
what do I think is a solid rating to
find solid I mean any rating like you
can always improve like even where I'm
at I think if there were more GM's
I played on me chess I'm sure they would
be like twenty seven twenty eight
hundred easily and rapid
but I guess like from a pure statistical
standpoint if you're if you're in like
the 99th percentile and then that's
that's pretty solid right that would
probably be like twenty to twenty three
hundred but it takes a long long time
lots of hard work lots of experience to
get to that point
am I too quiet I'm sorry I can speak
slightly louder I'm using a different
microphone today because microfiber use
it was having some static issues I
couldn't figure out I can boost the gain
to let me know if it's quiet for maybe
it's okay for other people
all right I could take I mean that let's
just take and then Queens c5 preparing a
five maybe he's starting to look at f2
Patrick J MT is back you're back in the
u.s. where were you you were like in
Japan Tokyo yeah I saw you in the chat a
few weeks ago pretty sure you were Tokyo
for three months and just enjoying life
like vacation order or making math
videos I played this looks like a fun
move let's play this very multi-purpose
make moved for the king and creating
meeting ideas enjoying life nice guys
very close to going to Japan when I was
in Thailand free pond
but Japan was slightly out of the way
it's also slightly more expensive yeah
this was another point of ah5 was to
induce h4 okay I just want to take a
look at the opening because Queen a4
check it's kind of a secondary line main
line is usually nine f3
the cornea 4 is still very playable
I know c6 is on a sine line and then I
played b5 so main line and yeah this is
mean based on what happens it's probably
not a great move this takes takes takes
stockfish let's get some answer
stockfish likes black between c2 just so
much initiative oh he played through
basically the best variation for both
sides
all right back to tournament yeah so a
couple points from my opponents if
you're gonna play that line again either
don't take on c6 just like Queen c2
immediately or learn the main line with
with nine of three and staff see thanks
for subbing twitch prime for three
months do you have any tips when playing
blitz I spot a tactic pattern and I
instill a it yet three to four moves
later there's something that refutes it
yeah sometimes a thing about blitz is
you have to rely on intuition and it's
hard to spend time like delving into
tactical ideas let's play another London
so so I'm not just to get better at
quicker time controls you have to get
comfortable playing slower times
controls you play a lot of like 10
minutes or 15 or whatever classical
chess then you build up a lot more
intuition and experience in terms of
calculating but then also just solving
exercises - if you solve more you'll
you'll become more confident in looking
at like forcing variations okay so we
have some sort of like Pierce started as
a London h5 very mysterious
do I need to play h3 I want to play nine
of three but don't have to and don't
want to worry about Bishop g4 it can
also play f3 strange strange opening
there's also this move takes takes
I'm tempted to play e5 right away
because I oh wait there's takes and so
maybe you not have three first three
Bishop g4 85 takes takes
you know it's fine on three you
recommend blitz for learning rapid not
sure if I understand that question like
whatever the time control is you have to
adapt to it
now e5o let's play each three I want to
take too much time early on it's one
thing about rapid or blitz if the
position isn't too critical you should
be ready to move quickly save time for
later moments I'm just playing playing
simple setup at some point I do want to
play e5 attacking the b-pawn so now ii 5
there's 95 hitting my bishop let's just
castle so the fact that black is
committed to h5 it's a bit more shaky of
black castles I have access to g5
there's basics interesting move just
continue to improve
I grew up d1
yeah I know there's questions in the
chats which I can't respond to all of
them I have to focus
I'm already with running a long time
compared to my opponent so between games
that's when you can ask your questions
or in my discord channel I have a disc
or channel let me type in discord go to
ama ask me anything
okay e5 makes me very happy because now
bishop about this that's still Bishop h6
and c5 might come at some points critics
from with this d5 is a bit more tender
looking it takes takes and a4 there's
some funny trick that might happen
eventually like nine at four so I'm just
applying more pressure my thread is to
take in windy five
yes so this is a trick which I didn't
want to say just in case my opponent was
watching but whites and move and win a
queen
it's nice tactic family fork oh this is
a spoon it's almost a fork all right I
need a fork prop I guess we have the
fork nike boots very majestic fork night
am i winning I'm winning more material
I'm forking a king kind of nights that
crumbled very quickly for black I'm
gonna take the night I guess I'll lose
up to who cares about pawns I can win
another pot I was a rook let's play
let's play rook to you for
okay now I'm threatening to Anna pond
turning join many more plans
this night is actually just stuck with
another pond it's a meeting idea Queen
d2 King takes H work when h6 rook h5 not
quite play this move
I might have to make another Queen mr.
genius 102 thanks for subbing yeah I
said who cares about pawns a few few
seconds ago
my opponent clearly does not care and
threatening me in one
I just wants to get stalemated where's
the quickest make Queen takes King g4
quickest meets
maybe
we have six I'm looking for just some
simple made into hoping for a g5 here
all right that was fun
slightly questionable opening but really
came down so like one important tactic
there Knight takes c6 just fell asleep
and woke up did I make you fall asleep
you're welcome or I'm sorry I don't know
what to say
g5 or King g5 we're the only two moves
both were pretty losing giant-killer
let's play e4 this game I played a
couple London's I'll play some play
something
let's play a Spanish Spanish is like one
of those popular openings and chests
which I probably don't play enough of
Bishop c5 is not a line that I've
studied like so thoroughly as this um
move takes takes T for that looks like a
move Center for trick okay this is
probably some theory but I mean d4 looks
so attractive so maybe my opponents just
playing quickly and not really playing
any theory play Bishop b3 a7 looks very
tender
I think Bishop g5 or queen f1 or Queen
f3 cause Bishop g5 there's h6 so d5 can
be coming so I'll play Knight c3 first
just restricting d5 very natural
flexible move
what tournament is this you can use a
tournament command in the chat my pot
will give you a link so Bach really
wants to play d5 I can play d5 myself
still play Bishop g5 its Queen h5 years
d 5 t 6
I think queen h5 actually makes a lot of
sense it looks like an aggressive move
but it's just a prophylactic move I'm
controlling d5 another time
so black can't really fight for the
center oh no one uses a turn to come in
so I'll use the tournament commands
there you go if you want to join the
tournament it's a daily rapid arena
there's an hour and six minutes left I'm
in sixth place with 20 points happy
robot how it has 33 points so I still
have some catching up to do
yeah queen f1 was playable my rook on a1
belongs on f1 now this looks very
attractive because like now all the
pieces are kind of coming to life and
there's a key variation here that of h6
I can take and if Queen takes I take on
g6 so a Bishop e6 interesting move
trying to neutralize
a very reasonable move maybe D 5 D 5
takes my tics take sticks
I'm giving away a 5
also allowing Queen b6 ideas it still
looks good though I think I'm getting
more getting more than I'm giving away
because I really want a piece like a
knight or a bishop to land and define
and the site still pins but I really
just want to get so left a sudden pawn
so there's some line I take stick stick
sticks hitting be Savin your Queen b6 I
wouldn't take then it takes a nun Bishop
tix King h8
so maybe I'm winning upon at some point
someday how do you make tea with a pot
do you put tea bags in the pot or just
hot water in a bag in the cup
you just have a personal assistant and
they do it all for you and you just sit
back and relax and play chess but if I
make my own tea I boil the water put it
in a pot I have a tea boy ler those
things plugs into the wall takes I think
I should take is if I play rock up one
first you five and my bishop said so
I'll take first light still pins bishops
now open rook af1 is coming
man it's really just a matter of
achieving length ideal subah mmm really
all the pieces are on there I think
they're ideal squares maybe the night
can be improved depending what black
takes with black takes with pawn and
yeah my knight maybe wants to go places
okay Bishop e6 makes sense
so there's ideas of this but it walks
into initiative I mean I could take take
wait a minute is this winning this is
winning they just take take they take on
f8 Queen f7 King eight shades I went
east seven then I fork the Queen in the
night and the ends forcing moves Bishop
e6 it looked like a safe move at first
but it just loses the spots
that's the problem like the Knights
defending each other
yes this Knight is technically
overworked defending f8 and e7 now I
take here
all right hey I'm gonna pass a sermon I
think I mean one point to pass a sermon
Oh Queen b6 I forgot about if Knight g6
can i play this bishop f8 then there's
queen d4
I just want to finish the game in style
queen d4 so maybe I play e5 first
he finds a funny move because black has
to really deal with this threat taking
and after it takes then I play Bishop f8
and there's no Queen d4 and I think it's
just like force mates like takes Bishop
f8 there's no list for this cuz Bishop
takes you seven and if my take sticks
and I'm 8e five is one of the coolest
moves like I've ever seen
there's actually a book there's a book
called imagination in chess which has a
whole chapter dedicated to who's like e5
and the term that it uses it's called
reciprocal thinking where you have an
idea but the idea doesn't work for some
reason like M idea was Bishop I faint
but it didn't quite work who's Queen d4
so you have to play a move to first like
resolved issue like e5 resolving this
issue
maybe Bach will still play this but then
I can take on d6 Oh reciprocal thinking
our EC oh man feels like I'm in the
spelling bee are you see IP RI I think
there's an O in there and then a in
there somewhere
yeah Aries aughts I think spelled
correctly addition F fades
yeah e5 was nice I mean there is many
ways to win the position this was one of
the nicer ways the book imagination
about chess it's it's really aimed for
players I would say above 2,000 rated
and it's mostly a puzzle book but it's
um it's one of the books I used to help
get me from like FM's I am worked
through a lot of that book okay I'm in
fifth place
I'm higher either than Esserman I think
refresh rapid yeah I passed smn1 rating
points try and keep up the streak in
this opening in the okay that's advanced
French in the advanced French how do I
get rid of this e5 pawn usually you want
to break down the center with maybe well
maybe I'll try and induce my opponent
into a French he's playing a London East
six is not not the move I would play if
I knew my phone was playing the London
so it's lines where I wanted to vote my
bishop but I guess I have to live with
it
but yeah if you play advanced French you
want to play moves like c5 Knight c6 and
Queen b6 and sometimes later f6 okay
I'll play this move order
this is what Nakamura has fight against
Kamsky and I play d5 I'll play play one
of my my pet lines that's one of the
main lines to take wait a minute oh I
got confused this is not the main move
order usually this Bishop isn't on d3 I
mean I can still do it 9 h5 if I get
this position with not in d2 but this is
a bit different careless
this should still be okay 9h five and
use a Bishop d6 coming
and the night looks weird but I want to
find out for at some point but that's
better
it's a better position if the night was
here in the bishop's still here okay
let's play g6
hello to Poli what are these names with
underscores I don't understand there is
another name jab with like this long
underscore it's like you guys have a
tail Oppo Lea was taken uh-huh so you
just add them interesting
so I'm keeping my night here because
some some day I might want to play off
65 also ideas a few encountering my
nights playing nyla five ah you love the
Komodo challenge nice yeah that was a
really fun event hopefully there will be
more events like that contains a smoke
Queen h4 g3 Knight takes g3 Bishop f2 oh
it doesn't quite work I play at six the
f6 it looks very strange are you in most
openings if you push all these pawns
it's very weakening but here it's
actually a very solid
now I'm attacking f4 like continue with
Queen b6 whoa free pawn
people are so generous sometimes it
takes g6 own I take his g6 I didn't even
consider um that may have been working
that was probably just crushing thing
yeah thankfully he didn't play it
whoa nineties g6 just as I was saying
these pawns are like solid that would
have been like just devastating oh man
takes takes takes I would lose two pawns
maybe I get like accidental compensation
the Queen g8 that would not be fun to
come back from okay here on ohon g5
looks very pleasant
I am green welcome back or I am me green
that name sounds familiar I think I saw
you in the u.s. Ches broadcast thanks
for watching that thanks for joining
here did I ever do the elo meter test
yes I did it maybe nine months ago
there's a video on YouTube type in my
name and ela meter can find it let's
play Queen h4 Queen h4 Queen b6 Queen h4
expecting Queen off - whoa okay this is
looking nice Oh usually you watch
YouTube channel yeah YouTube in twitch
they have different dynamics and for
some people they prefer watching like
afterwards some people like it's it's
more fun watching alive because you
don't know like what's going to happen
and you can interact in real time so I'm
in fourth place I'm playing Mark Brett's
let's play efore hey kind of pink Jake
slobbing for two months only two months
it's like you've been here for longer
but thanks okay I'm playing a knight c3
Sicilian
what is this country Belgium I was in
Belgium in February but only flying
through spent like five hours at the
Brussels Airport and the Brussels
Airport had like the best like free
Wi-Fi I've ever seen like there upload
speed was like 500 megabits a second
it's insane I was in Belgium like a few
few summers ago I went to Bruges and
also spent a few days in Brussels a nice
country nice waffles good chocolate too
so ok a very typical Grand Prix setup
also common structure for black usually
I'll go for a d3 Queen e1 queen g3 or
Queen h4 maybe I'll start with Queen e1
oh you've been here for longer but just
at Lu gifted us up first month and you
knew you needed to continue that's nice
things just a blue for starting starting
a nice relationship have you submitted
feature requests blindfold and
text-to-speech we just has a feature
they have text-to-speech I have it here
if I wanted to I could very quickly
change this to a blindfold right greeny
one night f7 no it's seven it has this
weird bug where when you adjust the
volume it just keeps saying 9 f7 I'm
going to not use that tradition takes 3
wait what
[Music]
it has multiple sounds route takes have
three
this
people hear this gh1 it has the text of
speech and the pentatonic sounds I know
you can do both at once having to mute
this okay
I need my speaker volume - yeah there's
some it's not like a huge issue but some
minor bugs with that this may be a
result of like the version 2 updates
like the code being rewritten so we have
a position which is maybe not the most
typical for Grand Prix with black house
and Queen side cuz usually white is
ready to like attack on the Kings side
so what I might do is like play Bishop
III and eight push the a pawn like a 45
and when I joined the tournament I did
not have an intention of playing the
full thing I might I might be playing
the full thing 47 minutes left about
hello [ __ ] for from Greece it's good
to see a lot of like international
viewers think I'm streaming at a
relatively decent time we're like even
in Greece it should be maybe it's late
in the evening but not too late let me
know where you guys are from it's always
interesting I've done this before I just
ask people to tell me where they're from
then we'll get a lot of a lot of places
we have Boston Faro islands Apple chess
what's up Germany Norway also Greece
France Germany England Belgium Turkey
Bulgaria Sweden Albania Netherlands
Denmark Malaysia
I assume that's Israel it looks like
Hebrew characters Germany Brazil Munich
Indonesia shallots Indonesia I was just
very last month or not last month but at
the beginning of the year Texas
Netherlands Philippines Caribbean
Bulgaria Australia h5 is kind of scary
because if I take I get crushed
I could play 90 to 92
I apologize for house sounds I don't
know how loud that is hopefully it's not
too loud yeah I want to play ninety-two
and just chase away the Queen also open
up my queen better prepare a four a five
whoa
we have we have more places Portugal
Nigeria and Mara's polymesh Michigan
Denmark Minnesota Switzerland Germany
Turkey that is Israel in Hebrew nice
Pennsylvania UK abundant but in Saudi
Byron Bay where is that Austria I'm in
st. Louis I'm in the cave you guys can
use the location command and updates my
location usually okay if I was a good
move maybe I'd complain this
I've moved my rook back and forth enough
times but I want to take the knight and
just play king g1 Copenhagen Ireland
it doesn't stop I am from the USA I'm
playing a tournament tomorrow
starting tomorrow a real-life tournament
not one of these online tournaments my
most hated subject in school I took a
weight I took like a few gen Ed's which
were just like really badly organized
it's like um it's one class I was
actually looking forward to it's just
the content was was unfortunate it's
philosophy really any subject that
involved writing was not not so fond of
I liked the more practical courses took
a course in web development was one of
my favorite courses or like graphic
designer photography okay Bishop e7 what
to do I really want to play b4 b4 it
takes a 5v5
a6 what does that position maybe Queen
off to first before it takes a thigh
let's do this first
as before it's just such a cool move to
play if it ends up working good time to
be accepting crypto oh yeah I don't
think I think there's only been one
person in the history of me streaming
that has donated Bitcoin but I think
stream ops is still set to take like
Bitcoin like coining aetherium yeah I've
been it's maybe following this crypto
space closer a while ago but yeah
there's been some good numbers lately
okay can I get away with us before it
takes a five takes takes looks fun let's
do it if C takes I take here and I went
upon it's a cool move it's not so often
you can play a pawn move where it's
supported by nothing and like two
different pawns can take it but it's all
about opening lines the two lines I want
to open our a file on this diagonal so
black just ignores me plays g5 try to
open up lines of his own I think I can
take this should be working out well
very weird name back with the weird
questions some of these questions are
just too difficult to answer
yeah the London course used to be like a
hundred dollars
I mean it's eight hours of video content
but now it's it's still priced you know
it's priced at like thirty dollars now
again if you want to find the course
there it is this is a great position
so I wanna pawn lines are opening up
let's say with Knights do I recommend
the physical version um probably not the
physical version is like a DVD unless
you have like a DVD player but no
digital like you get all the files I'm
pretty sure there em mp4 files so they
should be readable on most any device
but it's all managed through IHS so I
don't really help with customer support
but I do have a sense of like the the
content
so yeah if people have questions
regarding like the formatting structure
or the files like how to how to use them
once they're purchased it's best to
reach out to IHS for that okay let's
focus on cleaning up
maybe e5 to figure out the position
still a bit closed
but you five looking at the system this
but my bishop is sad then let's play
rook b1 I'm very flexible I just read
the comment h5 is free
h5 is free but it's not a Paul I want to
take there's no need to open up files
like that
now maybe 96 going after the rook
I had an IG 6 before yeah maybe like the
concrete problem with 9 h5 is Knight g5
and then this is attacked and this is
attacked
can be split blow I moved back and then
I forgot what happened I for I force a
reasonable move maybe let's move
or maybe ticks
mmm Bishop c5 looks reasonable busy 5 is
also hanging so this Knights is doing
work I mean I can take end up meeting
actually my night probably wants to land
on on a five
or the queen will land on c6 I mean
there's really only one concern is g2 I
don't think it's a huge issue as long as
I keep initiative
you always have to calculate stuff like
this this is the thing when like when
you're in a losing position you can try
and go all out and when you're winning
you have to like be aware of these last
tricks there's no way off takes g2 works
for one I could just run her up g5 so
rg5 I think I can take on hey fine King
here here I trade queens of king b8 I
check and then I'll take on deeds that
move I forgot about but again there's no
way this is working I mean I could just
take let's just take care keep it simple
tajen zero asking hair do you ever have
problems recognizing patterns from
switching to 2d or from 2d to real
pieces no I used to probably I'm trying
to think back well there's so such a
nice potential meet of like promoting
tonight to make sure I don't have all
the Queen on I want to remove this rook
so then this would this can be mates i
all down all traits alt no oh do i hold
down control ok thankfully I'm not
getting needed but I guess I hold down
control and not alt I really wanted the
satisfaction of promoting to night with
check
okay I was over a five rupee six all
right yeah I know switching from 2d to
3d is sometimes an issue for some
players but the more chess you play the
more it just becomes just a position in
your minds and if there's people out
there who have problems switching back
and forth you just need more practice
with each medium and over time it'll
just be be comfortable in both hey
mentioned my leech house on twitter and
retweet me chests I'm playing Vivek
Varma I fled before and once before I'm
one with whites all right let's play
this is suing me chest retweeted if
people want to look at Twitter you can
use the Twitter command in the chat
let's play a six a six is slight
slightly a secondary line but very
intuitive I'm not playing the dragon
my phone's playing close the ceiling in
any way very slim grand-prix attack if
he's in third place so this is actually
he matchup
why arrogance came from YouTube welcome
to twitch I feel like a good portion of
the the viewers came from YouTube I
think there should be seven threatening
to win a pawn
when d3 might be expected Bishop d3
Bishop d3 I have c4 Bishop b2 b4 night
b1 very skeptical of this
oh there's some funny lines e4 Bishop e2
before assuming Knight be one tick
sticks
now I have Queen c7 hitting this and
this then there's d3 things get messy
so I've d5 right away hmm okay let's
start with c4 I'll probably go for this
as I chase the knight back I'm gonna
Center pawn here I have east six oh one
c-- four I guess I play d5 let's just
take I'll play d5 very soon monster doe
the monster Z DotA thanks for subbing
for two months
do you three might come to play five
first j5o a5 Bishop a4 9 of 6
yeah let's play 906 natural move
probably bishop
just completing developments yeah so d4
now this is a very nice square for black
question do I play this for this
Bishop d6 I kind of wanted this diagonal
I guess my Queen belongs on b6 let's see
three normal wait I can win a pawn maybe
takes bishop takes off for coming
ooh but then Bishop III should be there
check it's a little bit tricky I think
I'll just Castle I wanted to play this
but I think white would get too much
condensation
this nights kind of annoying
I'll be annoying back doesn't care about
pawns just cares about attacking okay
now it looks like a free pond I can just
take this Bishop d2 I take another pond
this Bishop is also tied down to the
Knights if g 5 probably ninety seven
yeah the Queen is actually quite
annoying for whites on c3
yeah I've been life for a while it's not
where you're calling me now tea boy
what's that other username tea Kong one
of the best usernames Queen g2 Queen d2
maybe Bishop to b4 because if takes
takes Iruka strapped some nice nifty
little battery i'll Queen B - I didn't
see that coming that looks playable
compl a ruck orgoth c8 just leave
attention
yeah why not think soon that I want to
play 96 just go after this pawn look do
you one reasonable maybe a five first
look solid
so I'm up upon it still got mighty 27 27
minutes and 36 seconds left the first
opening I learned a long time ago
mmm when I started playing chess without
really knowing openings now I would just
play like standard like Italian for
Knights like basically e4 Knight a3
Bishop c4 Knight c3 every game then like
I got a coach and then we kept a
notebook of like various openings so
basically had a whole efore repertoire
like one of the first openings I learned
in depth was the molar attack basically
I'm coming from an Italian with early c3
d4
and that was an opening which was very
effective against like lower level
players because white is aggressive
early sometimes acts upon and gets a lot
of attack so I learned that pretty
deeply I learned open Sicilian
variations mainly classical variations
learn the tirage variation against the
French
well then over time I just keep
expanding my my racket or my doing
anymore st. Louis videos um nothing on
the near horizon I'll be playing a
tournament in st. Louis which I don't
think they're doing commentary for
unfortunately that they will be
broadcasting the games it should be at
least on dgt but in terms of like the
standard lectures I've done for them in
the past nothing on the near horizon
but there's a chance so like sometimes
I'll be asked to fill in they need
someone
all right tics yeah III is another bad
move good play Bishop t6 just keeping
all the tension be happy to trade Queens
and gather rook to to c3 Bishop a4
wish before it's a good move take sticks
taking 96
even takes first
this Bishop t2 in the end there I could
take on a three
baby king any king of head as well
why am I not sure what to do
takes takes my night is just kind of
stuck I guess I'll take in play 96 not
have to worry about the e5 fun
like I mop up all and I just want to
keep things simple like a decently high
rated player yeah that's a reasonable
move it's 98
yeah my knight wants to come to d6
maybe at six
so it says an 87 mm play rook b8 first
can I keep up some pace have six ideas
rook d7 maybe ideas of doubling up not
sure which file I want to double up on
just know I want to double up on on some
file Wow f5 I find maybe taken me five
first there could be a lot of initiative
coming I'll take first takes Knight c5
Bishop has to move back to d1 I think
the 93 Hut the bishop should move
somewhere
and it's still very solid position for
luck
I guess I can take forgot about that
move
it's a reasonable move and you have to
be careful how they have to play rook c7
okay now 93
if takes I'm not sure if I take with
neither rook I take with night
Bishop d4 Knight b5
I could take with night here up with an
eye maybe you lose a pawn don't take
with pawn it's a reasonable move let's
keep the Knights on the board Lisa smite
defending e6
it's a little bit tricky let's move the
rook here so we can't access the square
which is good
it's actually a very good move let's
play let's play this
so I had Rick b3 b3 over then takes it's
not so simple
also rupee one rupee one check the king
is maybe being hunted
I mean I might be losing my own my a
pawn but I have ideas like a six to c5
maybe winning back they thought I'd use
later of 93 as well which could be
causing problems for the king
okay down the minutes
booth getting a long time just a meeting
this or this okay let's play the smooth
looks a little bit shaky
okay I guess I'll take latex
no no that blenders probably
okay
thinking of southern person to move much
quicker
you have to is very strange if you had a
free pawn now it's not so simple go
enter name 93 and taking e5 King me 396
hitting e5 also ideas a bishop see to
hitting a 400 we might have some hostile
art bishop engine
I'm up upon the count on time
this pond wants to roll in rock
oh I didn't see that coming
sixteen seconds flight went upon
it's going to be a draw
phones trying tricky stuff
oh the draw there goes my win streak am
i reading
sadly good game though really tried yeah
the ending was tricky you started
playing well around around here and it's
tough there's a lot of like annoying
initiative for whites and then okay that
should be a draw here if he just takes
but he's playing for a win
hung out a little bit far I'm here okay
I played this too quickly I should just
take and take and there's still some
chances it's still tough I have four
check yeah sure I have opportunities
okay
good game of time for one more so my win
streak
what was my win streak I'm still in no
loss Street but we go reading stats my
access
my win streak is here 71 games oh did it
end on e oh it ended April or maybe it
hasn't updated huh
alright I'm playing ksv 79
are you playing on once oh we already
played forget my opening that was let's
play a g6 opening
well then go after this pawn I'll play
e5 94 saw an interesting Kings Indian
move order now c5 I believe c5 or a
Bishop g4 member maybe Bishop c4 is
playable
seems so close to working takes takes
Queen h4 there should have to.i mates
the problem is Queen h4 tonight g3
doesn't work
so I have to take okay I'll take off
play Bishop d7 will still get a
structure Simon Simon Simon Simon Simon
oh I didn't have a night at four cuz my
knight was pinned yeah there's this pin
right so many people want a Seibel
actually it's just I am me green and a
few other people too this takes a lot of
energy to play this whole tournament I
still have to go for a run today so and
I have a tournament starting tomorrow
well the chat has just turned into like
Simon was this I said the same thing
yesterday oh yeah
I'll do it let's do a similar term it
finishes I'll do one of those like
gigantic Simon's how about just remind
me later just have to keep reminding me
but not now
you've reminded me enough now f4 is very
aggressive before is a good move I have
to be careful I mean f6 looks very ugly
maybe Queen okay f5 is coming so maybe
takes in Queen see it just hit the pawn
someone said Simon John Davis and the
chats
yes Imel and the thing about sidewalls
it's just so tiring and I need to be
like mentally prepared which I'm not 300
bits
I missed Oh for all the missed G fives
in the past couple of weeks
yeah there's been multiple times where I
played g5 and I say shout outs all of HS
but sometimes just missing you can i
play this one looks like a playable move
I could push it upon not sure where my
king should go
so scary moved to play like there might
be potential sacrifices later but it's
trying to make the most of it I want
something clean do you one probably or
eventually five the a6 b5
it seems slow but my bishops nice okay
white definitely wants to play e5 so b5
if we take a bunch I when a2 and then if
I 5 I can take five all right
trying to stir up some initiative yeah
always play off 5 so then you'll never
be able to play off 6 something I
discovered very recently oh if I take
them ticks ticks ticks ticks ticks
it's playable let's do it this game I'm
slightly tilted from last game so this
game I'm relying a lot more on intuition
so Bishop takes ok I like this Bishop
both bishops have some potential
yeah now both bishops are very nicely
opened bangle take take first maybe
repeat next as long as I don't allow
this pawn and the bishop to be happy
then I'll be happy is it wrong to find
happiness in someone else's sadness
I guess so that's how chess works right
all right Queen b7 coordination is
forming there's a lot of pressure here
starting to look for tactical ideas
between before first this bishops not
defended let's play Queen before Bishop
b3 maybe I just pushed yeah I can no
longer play off six g5 is also pretty
unlikely even though Lee chess allows me
to cream of g5 can I pre move like Queen
I fades oh I can but I can't remove like
Kim D Keaney four or something
interesting
all right so a5 looks just very natural
anything else
there's some ideally if this bishop
wasn't here of queen takes c3 then rook
b1 mates and then my uptime is over two
hours man I played this full tournament
I'll be finishing I win this game I'll
finish in a tie for fifth looks like
nine eight for the tournament ends soon
therefore Queen B one around Queen here
Bishop c2
looks good enough
like I'm threatening made in one I'm
calculating Bishop C to Queens C for
pinning the bishop driving a to and if
King B 1 the bishop would be pinned to
the King and I would take the knight so
there's multiple targets here b2 also
targets I mean all these lines not
associated with b2 which is aligned with
my rook and Bishop as well when does my
tournament starts you can use what does
the upcoming command come in anymore I
made this earlier and you can click the
link with more information you can see
the pairings of fields schedule I have
my my also my schedule command I put in
all the rounds I still need to update
the descriptions Queen c2 and now I can
start considering fun moves how do I
have the most fun
Queen beef wait my queen came from
before unfortunately sinking Queen
before here
Queeny five
just trying to hit like multiple targets
Queen c2 is probably one of the better
moves to play
now what Yorick before I already have so
much pressure but now I'm just trying to
increase the pressure just a little bit
like bring this rook to b8 and something
should collapse for whites
yeah Queen a4 I consider it Queen a4
takes takes takes I didn't see how I'm
winning anything it's a pretty fancy
trade so my Queens attacked it's
probably queen bee five yeah I'll have
some triple battery this King has no
safety I can't access b1 I'm finding
this okay
and iPhones putting up resistance for
the Queen on b7
I don't think this game will finish
before the tournament ends because
there's 45 seconds left in a turn
minutes so I'll finish in like top ten
not bad showing off a cha saying I've
heard you floating some ideas of
streaming your prep have you figured
that out yet
yeah as much as I would like to stream
my prep that would be honestly very
idiotic
because the whole point of preparation
is that you keep it secret from your
opponent so I might record my prep and
then post it to YouTube probably after
the tournament finishes but I'm also
concerning or streaming game review
where I just do like daily video recaps
on the over the board games that I'm
playing but it depends how much time and
energy I have there's some days with two
games so we'll see
but I definitely want to make like some
kind of content around this tournament
I'm playing the st. Louis norm Congress
again I'll use the upcoming Commission's
upcoming it starts tomorrow
yeah there's one game like tomorrow I
think late afternoon and then games over
the next several days there's two
sections because it's designed for
players to get norms Bishop a4 can I
take that I was actually kind of more
scared of 95 I was stronger but okay
the pressure is being increased yeah the
tournament has an IM dorm section g and
warm section so if you don't know what
norms are you can google it but it's
basically it's how players fulfill the
requirements to either get the I in
title or the GM title so I'm not going
for norm I'm playing in the I am norm
section and so I'm basically an ion
that's being there to help fill the
requirements for other players to try
and get their iron norms but that
doesn't mean I'm not going to like take
it seriously
we still try and fight hopefully play
some interesting chess I take I mean I
just really want to sack it's gotta be
good right take stakes
not seeing a clear follow up
oh let's put thiking somewhere safe dur
safer getting off diagonal maybe my
night will come in eventually play Queen
c6 here get all my pieces are any
perfect okay let's take this you seven
might come I want to play a for now that
this rook is no longer there I can play
a four and win be to t5 I really want to
take that Knight g5 not a bad move
this is turning into a long game
I think I've officially finished in
seventh place least according to the
standings take stick sticks
yeah now I'm trying to take here and
then take you with check also finding
the bishop and I'm already up a queen
and coupons for rook and Bishop one
thousand bits if I ever meet with g5 I
mean it's still possible in this game
race but I my opponent will probably
resign before I get to that point unless
he doesn't resign then I'll try it
all right well that finished it was a
fun little fun middle name position
because around here it looked like I was
getting squeezed
maybe f4 was a little too early or the
combination of that foreign castling
queenside and then playing me five like
white over extended a little bit and
then my pieces came to life what you
wrote d4 be good
rook t4o work d4 may be in this position
would be good I forgot the bishops
obstructed Bishop c5 instead of Bishop
g1 Bishop c5 yeah I mean Chad is finding
moves which I I was missing during the
game honestly did not see Bishop c5 like
it's important that the rooks defended
the bishops defendu yeah oh I would have
rookie 4 so it's not that bad am i a
typing master like typing on the
keyboard it depends on the keyboard but
usually like I'm still having some
struggles especially with numbers I try
sometimes
okay well thanks guys for watching I
appreciate the people in the chats lots
of lots of lots of interaction
engagements nice viewership yeah you
guys can follow my games there should be
there should be like a broadcast I would
have imagined us chess champs this is a
website I'll imagine there will be like
a live like watch live somewhere if
there's not then you'll just have to
follow my stream keep an eye out for
when I go alive alright
also congratulations to happy robots for
winning the tournament pretty dominating
score looks like the robot drew the last
game 56 points I only had 34 points by
only guy I deserved a single game guess
next time if I want to win I'll have to
to bezerk so what to do ooh people are
streaming multiple people are streaming
getting another robocall
I'm sorry who's calling yeah who's
calling I'm talking to a robot hello can
you hear me hello who am I talking to
and why are you calling me okay it's one
of these like AI things which they call
you it sounds like a real person but
it's not a real person okay I I think
that will be the end of the stream let's
raid someone ooh
bowties and Ana are doing duo stream oh
[Music]
it's like the same oh they're squad
streaming can I read both of them it's
just rain boat s or wait no let's raid
the person with less furious let's rate
ana and a chess alright goodbye everyone
good night good evening good afternoon
if you want my discord there's a discord
commands
okay thanks guys for watching see you
all later